blade Smith's congratulations you've
made it to the final round of this
competition when you showed up here we
had you make mono steel blades with blue
handles to honor big Blues
now we're sending you back to your
HomePort just to recreate an iconic
weapon from history
it's a rock throwing crossbow gentlemen
The Rock throwing crossbow also known as
a stone bow was developed in the 14th
century but gained popularity without
doorsmen during the 17th century instead
of sharpened corals or Bolt projectiles
the stone bow was loaded with small
stones or pellets the stone bow
harnessed less launching power than
warbows as they were specifically
designed for hunting games silently
it's small stone or pellet projectiles
were readily available and left its
Target and tarnished or destroyed by
punctures from the steel tipped arrows
preserving pelts for luxury clothing
this made it a popular weapon among
experienced hunters and a perfect choice
as a young Hunter's first crossbow
good luck blade Smiths we'll see you in
four days
Craig Miller I've been working with my
hands for my entire life I make
everything I've built my own cameras I
built a vending machine when I was five
years old so this is just the next step
along the line I'm going to work with a
piece of ADC rv2 today for the prod it's
a really good durable steel how that's
shaped how that's tempered is really
going to affect its performance
it's just about there we can get it up
just a little bit more I'm heating up my
bow the Heat's looking even it's looking
pretty good I think I'm gonna go for it
we're in and no pops no cracks I'm
feeling good about it right now
oh yeah see that that's
that's a pretty sound
so now I'm doing a lot of finer fitting
marrying up the trigger to the release
things like that I'll have to fine tune
a little bit more that's fine but for
now everything's starting to fit
together as a whole if you watch here
you can see if I put forward pressure on
this
it's locked in
and once I hit the trigger it falls
forward that would be the the string
being released I made the trigger on the
bow to be relatively light to Aid in
accuracy on the weapon the less pressure
you have to put on the trigger the
easier it is to discharge it got all the
furniture put on there but otherwise I
mean it's it's mocked up on the bow I
got a lot of refinement to do so I'm
ready
my name is Colton Darius I'm 18 years
old I really love making something
that's going to last for a really long
time and it's also really fun to hit
stuff on fire I started out making
crossbows when I was really young so the
knowledge of the physics is like how
they work is definitely going to help a
lot in this challenge
so now it's time to Crunch the bow
so after I quenched I thought it went
well but when I go and take a second
look at it a warp has appeared if this
bow isn't symmetrical exactly one side
could be stronger than the other which
would cause the rock to fly at an
unpredictable trajectory I'm gonna have
to fix it one way or another so after
the bow and the string are complete I
move on to adjusting the struts and
friction fitting the bow to the stock
the thing I'm worried about most in the
construction is making the trigger
precise and making the draw weight not
too heavy but not too light as well the
trigger on this rock throwing crossbow
is made to basically hold a little loop
on the back of a pouch rather than
release a string with an arrow I
finished all of the metal parts and I
also finished up the stock
I'm gonna set up a Target and monitor
where it hits and how accurate it is
it's pretty lightweight and it's easy to
wield
Craig I've got the fortune fire
championship in my sights and I'm going
to be hitting my target
all right weapon Smiths welcome to the
kill test in case in this ballistics gel
is a mock heart I'm gonna attempt three
times to be able to pierce the heart
that's in it because the New York first
you ready for this yeah let's do this
thank you
foreign
let's talk about your rock throwing
crossbow first up it seems to be very
sturdy I like the spring spring loaded
right here on the trigger it's got a
nice weight to it now it was easy to
autocorrect after the first shot pretty
much sighted it right on straight dead
center both times with the shots in
there it didn't penetrate into the heart
but hit the target right in front of the
heart overall sir if this
should kill
all right Craig it's your turn are you
ready sir yes I am
yes
all right Craig so it's definitely a
more powerful crossbow that you have
here
the thing about this is that the sites
that you have on there is dead center
after the first shot a little bit low
adjusted for it it's dead on Center
second one ricocheted to the side of the
heart and then the third one it went to
the heart
your weapons sir we'll kill yeah it will
all right gentlemen it's time for the
impact test
to test your bows I'll be firing them
into our tempered glass here the idea of
course is to shatter that glass Colton
you're up are you ready do it
all right Colton the craftsmanship that
went into this weapon is is really
beautiful I like the trigger system
you've got here the catch the way you've
got the uh the stop pins for it to keep
it centered I like that you've got the
spring in there to keep that handle in a
locked position I like the way you put
the secondary leaf on the boat it's very
clever it doesn't have that strong a
draw weight but certainly it hits with
enough Force to break that glass well
done nice piece thank you
all right Craig you're up you ready oh
absolutely okay
that's a problem
Craig we've got a problem I never
touched the trigger
hmm
well it it would appear that I just had
an accidental discharge and that might
have just lost it for me
it doesn't take
anything now I made the trigger on the
boat to be relatively light maybe I made
it too light either way that presents a
danger to everybody
all right Craig something very serious
happened here on the forge floor we had
an accidental discharge with your weapon
Dave Baker never touched that trigger
foreign
this is a mechanical malfunction and
after reviewing the construction of your
crossbow the hook you made wasn't large
enough to hold the high tension string
securely creating a hair trigger and
that results in a very dangerous and
unpredictable weapon and has earned your
weapon a vote of no confidence and for
that reason we cannot continue testing
I'd like to invite you to shake my hand
shake the judge's hands and please leave
the forge
[Music]
I took a calculated risk to Aid in
accuracy and it turned around a bit me I
never made a stone throwing crossbow
before so I I don't have any regrets I
still want I just not getting paid for
it
strength and power matter when we talk
about any weapon but so do Precision
manufacturing and safety you sir are the
forest and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars good job brother
how do you feel right now amazing I
can't believe it well congratulations my
friend come shake our hands definitely
not the way I would want to win but if
you make a weapon that shoots when
you're not trying to shoot it it's not
very safe to use I just won Fortune fire
and honestly it's just now sinking it
it's kind of hard to believe this is a
dream from food for me